جاهز ،
نعم ،
لماذا تتقدمون طوال حياتي ،
لقد كنت بصدد البحث عن أماكن
يمكنني الذهاب إليها
وإحداث فرق ، هذا بيتر
زاكو حتى يناير من هذا العام ، كان
رئيسًا للأمن في تويتر ، لكنه الآن
مُبلغ عن المخالفات وهو يقول موقع تويتر
المشاكل الأمنية خطيرة للغاية ، فهي تشكل
خطرًا على الأمن القومي والديمقراطية ،
وأعتقد أن تويتر مصدر مهم
للعالم بأسره ، وأعتقد أنه
منصة مهمة للغاية قام
بتسليم معلومات حول الشركة إلى
وكالات إنفاذ القانون في الولايات المتحدة بما
في ذلك لجنة التجارة الفيدرالية والقسم
نحن نسأل عن اسمك في المنتصف
أنا موحل
زاكو معروف بشكل أفضل في عالم القرصنة
من خلال لقبه الوحل ، لقد كان
خبيرًا مشهورًا في الأمن السيبراني
لعقود من الزمن ، جذوره في القرصنة
لمعرفة كيفية عمل أجهزة الكمبيوتر
والبرامج التي قد تكون هذه الخبرة  لماذا جاك
دورسي ثم الرئيس التنفيذي لتويتر وظف زاكو
بعد أن تعرضت الشركة لهجوم هائل
في عام 2020 عندما استولى
المتسللون على حسابات بعض الأشخاص  أشهر الأشخاص في rld
كان mud واحدًا من أفضل
خمسة أو ستة مدراء تنفيذيين في شركة
zacco يمثله جون تاي الذي
أسس المبلغين عن المخالفات 8 وهي نفس المجموعة
التي مثلت فيسبوك المبلغين عن المخالفات
فرانسيس هوغن نحن على اتصال
بوكالات إنفاذ القانون التي يتخذونها
يقاوم موقع تويتر بجدية قائلاً إن زكاو ينشر رواية
حول ممارساتنا المتعلقة بالخصوصية وأمن البيانات
مليئة
بالتناقضات وعدم الدقة
ويفتقر إلى السياق المهم عندما تحدثنا إلى
زاكو ومحاميه قالوا إن
عملية الإفصاح القانوني للمبلغين عن المخالفات
تسمح لهم بالتحدث فقط  حول هذه
القضايا بعبارات عامة لادعاءات محددة
حول تويتر ،
أحالونا إلى إفصاح زاكو ،
لن أخوض في التفاصيل ، لكنني سأقول إن
الكثير يقف بجانب الإفصاح
والادعاءات الواردة فيه
cnn وحصل منشور واشنطن على
نسخة من  إفصاح من
مسؤول ديمقراطي كبير على تلة الكابيتول
فيه زاكو يدعي ما يقرب من ح  يتمتع alf من
موظفي Twitter بإمكانية الوصول إلى بعض
عناصر التحكم الأساسية الرئيسية في النظام الأساسي ،
وهناك تشبيه بالطائرة حتى
تصعد على متن طائرة ويمكن لكل
راكب وطاقم المرافق
الوصول إلى قمرة القيادة للوصول إلى عناصر التحكم
التي تعرف أنها غير ضرورية تمامًا.
كن سهلاً ، لكن من السهل جدًا
إيقاف تشغيل محرك حسابات تويتر عن طريق الخطأ أو عن قصد ، والتي
تنتمي إلى
مجموعة كبيرة من الأشخاص المشهورين ، وقد ساهم هذا النوع
من الوصول في الهجوم الهائل
في صيف عام 2020 عندما قام
قراصنة اثنان منهم من المراهقين بخداع
زوج من حسابات تويتر  الموظفين للسماح
لهم بالدخول إلى أنظمة تويتر التي
منحتهم الوصول إلى الحسابات بما في ذلك حساب
المرشح الرئاسي آنذاك جو بايدن ،
لست مضطرًا إلى إخبارك
بأهمية القدرة على اختراق
حسابات تويتر مع العديد
من الملايين من المتابعين بما في ذلك كبار
السياسيين لمدة ثلاثة أشهر  من
انتخابات رئاسية
في الكشف الذي اقتبسته من
مقال في مجلة سلكية يقول bu  إذا
كان بإمكان المراهق الذي لديه إمكانية الوصول إلى
لوحة الإدارة أن
يركع الشركة على ركبتيها ، فقط تخيل ما
يمكن أن يفعله فلاديمير بوتين
لدى وكالات الاستخبارات الأجنبية التي
لديها الموارد
لتحديد نقاط الضعف
التي يمكن أن يكون لها تأثيرات نظامية
عبر منصة كاملة عبر الإنترنت بالكامل.
منذ
الاختراق عام 2020 ، قام بتحسين أنظمة الوصول هذه
وكان لديه موظفين مدربين لحماية
أنفسهم من القرصنة إذا كنت تقوم
بتشغيل أي
نظام ، وكلما زاد عدد الأشخاص الذين لديهم إمكانية الوصول إلى
المفاتيح الرئيسية ،
هذا وضع محفوف بالمخاطر نعم أه
بالتأكيد أتحدث بشكل عام
تحتاج شركات التكنولوجيا الكبيرة فقط إلى
معرفة المخاطر ومن ثم يحتاجون أيضًا
إلى الرغبة في إصلاحها.
أساسي في
محاولته الخروج من صفقة
لشراء الشركة أعتقد الآن أه أنا
نوعاً ما أجادل في عدد الروبوتات  على
تويتر ،
ستكون هناك شكوك حول
توقيت هذا ، هل أنتم تحملون الماء من أجل
إيلون مسك على الإطلاق لم
نتابع الأخبار تمامًا مثل
أي شخص آخر ولكن هذا لا علاقة له
بقراراته أو بمحتوى ما
تم إرساله  في الولايات المتحدة وكالات إنفاذ القانون
mudge لم يتحدث إلى
المسك في الخلفية أو أي شيء
على الإطلاق
يقول زاكو إنه طُرد من تويتر في
يناير من هذا العام بعد أن حاول
إطلاق الإنذار داخليًا ، أشار
بإصبعه إلى الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة تويتر باراغ
قال agarwal إنه عمل على إخفاء
نقاط الضعف الأمنية على Twitter من مجلس الإدارة ،
وأظن أن تويتر قد يحاول
رسمها على هذا
النحو الذي أطلق عليه الوحل وهو يحاول
الانتقام من الشركة على
الإطلاق ، فهذه ليست أي
مشكلة شخصية بالنسبة له.  تم
طرده في نهاية المطاف في يناير من هذا العام ، لكنه
لم يستسلم لمحاولة القيام بهذه المهمة
ردًا على المزاعم التي أبلغت تويتر أن
الأمن والخصوصية في CNN كانا منذ فترة طويلة
بداهة  ty at twitter أما بالنسبة لـ
zacco قالوا إنه اقتبس من
منصبه التنفيذي الأول في Twitter منذ أكثر من ستة
أشهر لضعف الأداء
والقيادة ، ويبدو الآن أنه
يسعى بشكل انتهازي لإلحاق
الأذى على تويتر بعملائه
ومساهميه.
العالم
مصنوع مما تراه
تقرأه وتستهلكه عبر الإنترنت
، وإذا لم يكن لديك فهم
لما هو حقيقي ، فما هو غير ذلك ، أعتقد أن
هذا مخيف جدًا
، هل أنت متوتر ،
نعم ، لم يكن هذا خياري الأول ،
هذا نعم أنا فقط  تريد أن تجعل
العالم مكانًا أفضل مكانًا أكثر أمانًا ، فإن
الرافعات التي يجب أن أقوم بها هي من خلال
معلومات الأمان والخصوصية
أنت